madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal bill clinton donne une nouvelle
chance à la paix le président américain
exhorte saddam hussein à mettre fin à la
crise reportage à bagdad l'analyse de
nos envoyés spéciaux en irak et aux
états unis
la réduction d'effectifs plane sur
lusine cacharel anime c'est le dernier
atelier du groupe installé en france la
société cacharel sous traite à
l'étranger pour réduire les coûts
vallauris rendent un dernier hommage à
jean marais la ville toute entière est
en deuil pour les obsèques du comédien
lac lieu des anonymes et des gens du
spectacle la route du rhum dans un
mouchoir de poche laurent bourgnon paul
vatine alain gautier et glisse à la 3e
place la stratégie des navigateurs qui
ont choisi de mettre le cap au nord au
dessus de stratégie qui sera
déterminante
l'ultime espoir d'une victoire de la
diplomatie dans la crise irakienne avec
comme une dernière chance la réunion à
new york tout à l'heure du conseil de
sécurité en présence du secrétaire
général de l'onu kofi annan
tout au long de cet après midi la
fermeté des déclarations américaines
le nouvel avertissement de bill clinton
on attend maintenant la réponse de
bagdad le point avec jérôme benest cet
après-midi à washington le chef de la
diplomatie américaine a le ton de
l'ultimatum affirmant que les états unis
ont le droit de passer à l'action
tout pays respectueux de la loi a non
seulement le droit mais aussi la
responsabilité de faire tout ce qu'il
peut pour que saddam hussein ne soit pas
à nouveau une menace pour la paix dans
le monde
rice derrière cette détermination il ya
la machine de guerre américaine qui se
met en route
trois mille hommes et 129 avions de
combat qu'ont partance pour le golfe
persique où ils vont rejoindre les 23
mille soldats déjà sur place et une
flottille qui s'élèvera sous peu à 23
navires dont le porte-avions le moral
dans n'importe quelle unité toujours
plus haut quand c'est l'heure d'aller au
travail
alors on va aller là bas et on va
construire un aérodrome
en face les militaires irakiens ont beau
parade et chacun sait à bagdad que le
rapport de forces est plus que jamais
inégal le président saddam hussein vient
de faire passer le message auprès de
l'ambassadeur russe à bagdad qu'il est
favorable je cite à toute initiative
susceptible de satisfaire ses demandes
justes et équilibrées la tâche est rude
pour le secrétaire général des nations
unies kofi annan qui ne projettent pas
pour l'instant de se rendre à bagdad
tous les diplomates sont au moins
d'accord sur un point la balle est
aujourd'hui dans le camp de l'irak
saddam hussein a la possibilité de
mettre fin à cette crise en reprenant la
coopération avec les inspecteurs des
nations unies à mexico hier le président
français rappelle le rôle déterminant
que doivent garder les nations unies
seule l'onu dispose de la légitimité
pour parler et pour agir au nom de tous
malgré les réserves françaises
chaque seconde qui passe rend les
frappes contre l'irak plus probable avec
le risque de ruiner les dernières
chances de coopération entre l'onu et
bagdad
et tout de suite en direct de washington
est de bagdad de nos envoyés spéciaux
philippe heugas au fil des heures se
multiplient les déclarations de fermeté
américaine avec cette question si les
états unis aient recours aux frappes
aériennes le feront ils cette nuit c'est
plausible
bien qu est ce que l'on sait ici c'est
que bill clinton n'a pas annulé le
voyage de dix jours qu'ils comptent
faire en asie alors s'il y va vraiment
on voit mal l'amérique déclenché le feu
alors que le président ne serait pas à
la maison blanche
il reste donc quelques heures ou alors
il faudra que l'on parle de quelques
jours la détermination est bien là il
n'y aura pas de sommation
mais l'on a voulu souligner ici que si
le feu est déclenchée contre les troupes
de saddam hussein
il n'est pas question pour le moment de
faire partir le dictateur de bagdad
on a ici l'expérience d'un saddam
hussein qui après chaque frappe aérienne
apparaît dans les rues de bagdad pour
donner une conférence de presse
vous l'avez souligné tout à l'heure
le président clinton a pris la parole il
ya quelques minutes il a voulu donner
une nouvelle chance à la paix en disant
aux irakiens qu'ils ont encore le temps
d'inverser le cours des choses mais il
faut qu'il le fasse maintenant est
précisément nous retrouvons à bagdad
patrice romedenne au delà de la
provocation
que peut faire maintenant saddam hussein
qui se retrouvent ce soir au pied du mur
du côté béatrice les irakiens disent
qu'ils ont déjà tout donné qu'ils n'ont
plus rien à offrir sinon leur bonne foi
et qu'ils ne peuvent plus désormais que
recevoir alors en fait ce que les
irakiens attendent c'est une initiative
des nations unies ce sont les termes
employés au gérant bolivie allusion tout
à l'heure par saddam hussein qui
remettait tout à l'heure un message à
l'ambassadeur de russie en irak en clair
les irakiens sont prêts à reprendre la
coopération avec ruse comme à une
condition c'est qu'on établisse un
calendrier qu'on leur donne une date et
que l'on dit voilà tel jour on fait le
point sur le désarmement irakien et si
on voit que vous n'avez rien à vous
reprocher si on voit que vous n'avez
rien cacher eh bien on commence à lever
les sanctions et pourquoi pas l'ensemble
de l'embargo à bagdad est ce que vous
avez le sentiment qu'on peut se préparer
ce soir à une frappe possible oui
béatrice c'est un peu comme hier soir la
tension est montée un peu plus peut-être
aujourd'hui du côté des agences
onusiennes pour le personnel a été prié
de rester dans le bâtiment où le ces
gens là ont été rapatriés ils n'ont pas
le droit de sortir cette fois la
consigne est claire stricte officielle
et elle vient de new york
beaucoup d'irakiens soit vous nous dire
en disant faites attention cette nuit ne
vous inquiétez pas si les lumières
s'éteignent si vous entendez les sirènes
là cela voudra dire qu'il y à un
bombardement je dirais qu'on entame une
deuxième nuit de veille
en espérant que tout se passera bien et
que demain et bien tout sera en place
demain c'est le 14 novembre
ici à bagdad comme à paris d'ailleurs et
le 14 novembre et bien il y a une grande
fête qui est prévu à bagdad pour
célébrer l'anniversaire de la création
de la ville merci patrice voyons
maintenant comment la population à
bagdad a traversé cette journée ce
vendredi jour de repos
apparemment la vie continue entre la
crainte et le fatalisme patrice ramdane
et patrick voix ont suivi une famille
qui se rendait à la fête foraine
à bagdad les occasions de se distraire
ne sont pas si nombreuses qu'il faille
négliger la fête foraine
ainsi la famille à noir profite de son
jour de repos hebdomadaire 100 villes à
remonter dans l'avion à la grande époque
100 dinars cela correspondait à 1500
francs aujourd'hui la valeur du billet
excède à peine celle du papier sur
lequel on imprime 100 dinars il est
commerçant ne roule pas sur l'or certes
mais se défend dépit de l'embargo 100
dinars il s'en fiche qu'il fait ça pour
les gamines
si vous avez un problème financier
un problème de famille les enfants n'ont
pas à être au courant les petites elles
ont 5 et 6 ans ils ne savent pas ce
qu'est la guerre
parfois elle nous demande c'est quoi un
bombardement on leur répond que tant que
dieu existe il n'ya pas de crainte à
avoir
mais moi de mon côté je me dis que si
les bombardements arrive c'est le destin
en irak la peur est une notion étrangère
à l'univers masculin seul n'épouse
accepte de l'évoquer encore avec le
sourire
c'est sûr que quand on va se coucher ce
soir on n'aura peur on espère simplement
que tout se passera comme ce matin c'est
à dire qu'on se réveille qu'on voit que
tout est calme et on remercie dieu
cela dit on s'attend à tout mais vous
savez bombardements pas bombardements
bombardements pas bombardements pour
nous c'est la routine
c'était tout à l'heure entre deux nuits
incertaine un après midi agréable malgré
tout car ils savent depuis la guerre du
golfe que les bombes et les missiles
tout ça ça n'arrive jamais en plein jour
nouveaux affrontements à jakarta en
indonésie la violence dans le centre de
la capitale des milliers de manifestants
pour la plupart des étudiants se sont
affrontés à l'armée alors que
l'assemblée votait au même moment à une
très large majorité pour le maintien du
rôle politique de l'armée anne consigny
face aux 20000 manifestants la charge
des forces anti émeutes est ordonnée et
massive officiellement les fusils sont
armées de balles en caoutchouc et de
grenades lacrymogènes mais le bilan est
lourd au moins six morts aujourd'hui
dont trois victimes de tirs ces
manifestations à jakarta dure depuis
lundi mais avec une violence fortement
accru depuis hier les étudiants à
l'origine de cette agitation ont été
rejoints au cours de la semaine par des
foules de plus en plus nombreuses et
aujourd'hui c'est dans une ville au
magasin fermé comme en état de siège que
se sont déroulés les affrontements
ce sont les plus graves dans la capitale
indonésienne depuis mai dernier quand
l'ex président soir tous avaient
démissionné il ya vécu mille deux cents
morts aujourd'hui à l'hôpital des
rumeurs faisaient état de blessures par
tirs à balles réelles mais sans que cela
puisse être confirmé
les manifestants exigeaient que
l'assemblée réunie depuis mardi pour
étudier des réformes démocratiques
prennent des mesures radicales
suppression du rôle politique de l'armée
mise en jugement de l'ex président mais
au terme des débats le nouveau chef de
l'état a signé ce soir un texte modéré
les manifestants exigeaient une rupture
plus franche avec les 32 ans de
dictature dont essayer de sortir
l'indonésie en tant que barman ses parts
au nicaragua dans les zones les plus
dévastées la population constituée
essentiellement de paysans souffrent
d'avoir tout perdu dans ce pays à
majorité rurale des milliers de bêtes
gist à l'air libre des troupeaux entiers
décimée par les inondations comme en
témoigne le reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux
hervé brusini et jean-françois hoffman
les vautours en ont fait leur territoire
au nord du nicaragua le secteur de
pâques ou qu'à compter de multiples
ferme depuis que l'ouragan est passé
l'odeur de la mort est partout
ici ce n'est pas une route c'est une
allée de cimetière sept mille têtes de
bétail ont péri noyées dans la région la
puissance de la crue a emporté les
animaux jusque dans les arbres pour la
première fois depuis la catastrophe
la famille mento ça revient dans sa
petite exploitation tant qu il ne vous
reste plus qu'une paire de sandales est
autant s'en défaire est tant pis si la
boue est infestée de mick rock
justin a été fier de son jardin de ses
arbres fruitiers à présent la vingtaine
de vaches a disparu les 18 membres de la
famille n'ont plus de toit et l'aide est
absente pas dead pour brûler les animaux
morts pour manger oui un peu des petites
choses
c'est le mari de ma fille qui nous
envoie un peu de nourriture
la maison avait un puits mais bien sûr
ici plus question d'eau potable pour
l'instant c'est à des kilomètres à fille
que les deux fils de justin à trouve de
quoi boire
comment va-t-on faire avec nous parce
qu'elle est contaminée nous pour qu'on
revienne vivre ici définitivement
il faudra au moins au moins une saison
des pluies pour tout nettoyer et que
tout recommence à nouveau autrement dit
au moins un an avant de pouvoir se
réinstaller en attendant l'ouragan
replonger toute cette population dans un
absolu dénuement les risques d'épidémies
empêchent le retour des enfants
une situation insupportable pour le
grand père qui voit toute une vie
réduite à néant
jacques chirac devrait gagner le
guatemala demain avant de se rendre
dimanche au honduras puis au nicaragua
parmi la délégation des chefs
d'entreprises qui accompagnent le
président de la république
une quinzaine d'entre eux ont décidé de
répondre à l'appel du chef de l'état
pour apporter une aide substantielle aux
populations sinistrées de mexico
véronique saint olive jan cornet à
mexico ils savent tous qu'ils l'ont
échappé belle
épargnée par le cyclone qui a ravagé les
pays voisins alors la solidarité
s'organise à tous les niveaux partout
dans les rues aux quêtes pour les
médicaments
le président de la république a demandé
pour sa part au chef d'entreprise qui
l'accompagnent de participer à l'aide de
première urgence aujourd'hui le business
doit faire place à l'humanitaire le
président va demander de m'assurer que
les entreprises françaises faisaient
leurs devoirs dans jouer leur rôle dans
leur devoir de solidarité vis-à-vis des
populations sinistrées d'amérique
centrale matériel de filtrage d'eau
containers échafaudage ben la liste des
besoins est interminable
alors ce matin au petit déjeuner des
chefs d'entreprise se sont réunis pour
voir ce qu'ils peuvent donner chacun
dans son secteur
chacun selon ses moyens on va essayer
avec une quinzaine ou une vingtaine de
chefs d'entreprises de la délégation de
réunir les fonds pour offrir une dizaine
de maisons clés en main pour héberger
une dizaine de familles c'est peu mais
c'est la démonstration de volonté
aujourd'hui c'est désintéresse évoluent
et l'humanitaire et c'est de là ce nuage
et puis après il faut y aller alors
cette fois comme opérateur petites ou
grandes les entreprises ne sont pas
philanthropique celles qui manifestent
aujourd'hui une réelle solidarité
investissent aussi en terme d'image et
se positionne pour l'avenir l'actualité
sociale en france avec les menaces de
licenciement dans l' usine cacharel
anime cet atelier de fabrication
produits 15% du prêt-à-porter du groupe
le reste est sous traitée hors de france
parce que les coûts sont moindres et
c'est bien le combat difficile que
mènent les syndicats continuer à faire
vivre ces ateliers
face à la concurrence des tarifs à
l'étranger laurent bailly nathalie
gallet une usine fantôme des ateliers
déserté les ouvrières de la dernière
usine française de cacharel sont en
grève c'est 200 salariés attendent
d'être fixés sur leur sort
mais rien de précis le sortira de ce
comité d'entreprise extraordinaire
seule certitude un grand nombre d'entre
elles vont être licenciés car le textile
français ne tourne plus rond la
concurrence étrangère est féroce et ici
les salaires sont désormais jugés trop
élevés par la direction en ce qui nous
concerne le coût minutes qui sert donc à
calculer les prix de revient d'un
article le coc minutes chez nous est de
l'ordre de francs de francs 22 francs 30
alors qu'ils l'aident à francs 30 au
portugal et dans le sud de l'italie
les ouvrières bien sûr sont sous le choc
partagé entre une profonde amertume et
la peur du chômage
arrivé à un âge à 40 nouvelles je sais
que je retrouverai purines j'ai un passé
que tout est perdu
j'ai passé cette date de ma vie de la
société j'ai l'impression que d'ailleurs
nous balance comme un nouveau servi à
rien de guerre lasse elle ont repris le
travail mais elles ne comprennent
toujours pas à l'instar de cette femme
qui travaille ici depuis vingt ans qu'on
puisse reprocher aux ouvrières française
d'être trop payés par mois et entre 8h
et l'oignon rendra alors les regards se
tournent vers jean bousquet pdg de
cacharel et maire udf de nîmes jusqu'en
il n'a pas souhaité nous rencontrer
pourtant beaucoup pis ils lui reprochent
d'avoir fermé ses usines les unes après
les autres depuis qu'il a dû céder son
fauteuil
c'est une vengeance politique je crois
que c'est une logique implacable d'un
homme qui a voulu gouverner une ville
comme une entreprise et qui dirige son
entreprise comme on le faisait au 19e
siècle il y a quinze ans le groupe
employait 6 6250 salariés à nîmes dans
un mois on parlera peut-être de cacharel
au passé on appris aujourd'hui la
disparition d'yves hanchar l'ancien vice
président du cnpf aujourd'hui rebaptisé
le medef une haute figure de l'histoire
du patronat puisqu'il fut le négociateur
des accords avec les centrales
syndicales
de 1972 à 1986 yvon chotard que l'on
voit ici aux côtés d'yvon gattaz effet
perdu huit enfants il est mort jeudi
soir à l'âge de 77 ans en fin
d'après-midi les sans papiers qui
faisaient une grève de la faim dans les
locaux de la mairie de limeil brévannes
ont été évacuées l'état de santé de
séance personne était devenue précaire
il s'agirait d'une évacuation sanitaire
patrick fandio guillaume [ __ ] à la
mairie de limeil brévannes est encore ce
soir sous la surveillance des forces de
police quelques heures après
l'évacuation
voici de nouveau vie ou presque la salle
du conseil municipal
occupé depuis le 1er septembre la
descente de police a surpris tout le
monde
li a été investi pour tous les forces de
police et les pompiers
ils étaient très nombreux dans cette
salle qui ne peuvent très grande
après une soixantaine en uniforme et ils
sont installés tout autour des grévistes
de la faim est très rapidement donc les
pompiers sont arrivés les ondes
lauranne leur ont demandé de préparer
leur affaire et sont sortis avec eux les
neuf grévistes de la faim ont été
dispersées dans quatre établissements
sanitaires du département
trois sont hospitalisés ici à villeneuve
saint georges pour la préfecture cette
évacuation strictement sanitaire a pour
but d'éviter une dégradation de leur
état physique après 74 jours de grève
mais le maire socialiste juge
l'initiative maladroite
ce n'est pas par ce type de méthode à
mon avis on arrivera à régler le
problème des 60 premiers pas pris écrit
il doit d'être régularisés
on est en train de faire des clandestins
de ces personnes ses 63 ans un paquet
qui vont retourner dans la clandestine
et c'est cette clandestinité est un fort
appel à l'innovation
le collectif des sans-papiers du val de
marne dénonce ce qu'il appelle l'
irresponsabilité du premier ministre et
appellent à une manifestation ce soir
devant la mairie
le conseil constitutionnel a décidé de
ne pas transmettre à la justice le
rapport qui concernait la réélection de
jean tiberi aux dernières élections
législatives élections qui aurait été
entaché par des fraudes électorales dans
le 5e arrondissement de la capitale
xavi timbert laëtitia le guen solal est
déçu elle lit et relit la décision que
vient de rendre le conseil
constitutionnel le rapport sur la
réélection contestée de jean tiberi son
adversaire aux législatives dans le 5e
arrondissement
en clair l'enquète sur la possible
existence de faux électeurs
ce rapport du conseil constitutionnel ne
sera pas transmises à la justice s'en
lave les mains quelque part on n'a pas
elle venait que ce soit il reste secret
en fait il ya déjà un an et demi qu un
magistrat le juge chantal perdrix
s'intéresse aux listes électorales du 5e
arrondissement adresse fictive électeurs
votant ici tout en habitant ailleurs
voilà pour les accusations elle vise
directement jean tiberi le maire de
paris les a toujours contesté
je saisirai le constater que personne
n'avait porté un élément ce domaine
pourtant en février dernier le conseil
constitutionnel lui-même avait noté des
anomalies dans les listes il évoqué
explicitement des fraudes et des
manoeuvres
mais l'élection de jean tiberi n'avait
pas été annulé
son écart de voix avec lyne cohen-solal
près de 3000 étant jugé trop élevé pour
cela bien sûr quelques parents quelle
institution laisse passer la fraude pour
compte et simplement et se comportant
comptable je t'en mord alliés la
dernière décision du conseil
constitutionnel présidé par roland dumas
est en tout cas fort tu apprécies à
l'hôtel de ville autour de jean tiberi
en région parisienne des manifestants
tentent d'empêcher l'expulsion de sans
papiers algériens au départ du tgv de
l'aéroport de roissy les forces de
l'ordre dû intervenir sur place agnès
garder christophe pignol deux algériens
son papier ont été embarquées ce matin
dans ce tgv à destination de marseille
collectif anti expulsions syndicaliste
sud rail ils étaient une cinquantaine en
gare de roissy
déterminé à empêcher le départ du train
la manifestation a rapidement tourné à
l'affrontement
peut-on reconduire des algériennes et
des algériens mais j'aime pays qui vit
la guerre et qui fait la une de
l'actualité de tous les jours peut-on
renvoyer des gens du
généraliser c'est évidemment le
personnel d'air france étaient mobilisés
la semaine dernière c'est au tour des
cheminots il refuse aussi d'être
associés à ces mesures d'expulsion qui
l'expulsé le plus rapidement possible la
preuve ici une nouvelle gare tgv à deux
pas du centre de rétention
c'est une collaboration totale de la
sncf est aujourd'hui cimino disques y en
a marre de cette collaboration
on veut leur champ d expulsion les
militants seront finalement évacué par
les forces de l'ordre le train partira
avec trois quarts d'heure de retard et
les deux algériens arrivés dans l'après
midi à marseille devrait embarquer
demain à bord d'un paquebot direction
l'algérie en belgique un trafic
international de drogue démantelé depuis
le mois d'août dernier 180 kg de cocaïne
une tonne de haschich 100 mille pilules
d'ecstasy pour une valeur estimée à 29
millions de dollars ont été saisis par
la police cette personne arrêtée
d'autres interpellations devraient
suivre sur la côte d'azur une affaire
d'escroquerie concernant la vente de
timbres de collection avec pour
principales victimes des retraités
passionnés de philatélie
en tout plus d'un millier de personnes
unies vétéran fred v100 questionne notre
rêve avait des économies 2 millions de
francs elle achète deux millions de
fonds de timbres des blocs payer de
monaco vendues par une société valeur
philatélique dirigée par gérard
lhéritier
ils sont mille deux cents à avoir placé
leur argent sur des bouts de papier
aujourd'hui madame la taref n'a plus
rien ou presque
j'ai placé deux millions dix mille
francs jeu pour le moment je j'ai
récupéré je qualifierais des mégots et
puis et puis voilà et puis
l'avenir nous éclairera on verra bien si
nous arrivons à retirer quelque chose de
plus le rapport de synthèse de la
gendarmerie a établi des gains de gérard
lhéritier à 232 millions de francs sur
cinq ans le mécanisme est assez simple
l'état monégasque bénéficient de tirage
de timbres qui ne sont pas destinées à
franchir un courrier ils sont ensuite
revendus pour 14 millions de francs à un
intermédiaire sakho khatchikian comme le
montre ce chèque au bénéfice du prince
de monaco
gérard lhéritier rachète presque tout il
établit une cotation et fait miroiter un
marché pour l'avocat des plaignants les
complicités doivent être multiples les
gens que j'ai eu l'honneur de défendre
son se sont complètement abusé parce que
ils ont en effet rance une garantie sur
un placement financier
ils ont un catalogue et il espère
naturellement que le prix de vente et de
la revente des timbres soit
approximativement le prix d'un catalogue
comme la cote argus pour l'être pour un
véhicule automobile
deux éditeurs de catalogue de cotation
de timbres sont mises en examen pour
complicité d'escroquerie
gérard lhéritier lui aussi mise en
examen n'a pas souhaité réagir
publiquement
c'est son avocat qui a défendu la cause
de la philatélie à un monde de
spécialistes qui ne sont pas très
nombreux qui sont à la fois les vendeurs
et ceux qui estiment la valeur des
produits sur lesquels ils ont une
compétence particulière ce qui est tout
à fait normale et encore une fois ce
genre de phénomène existe également sur
des marchés comme celui de l'art
contemporain
le juge murcia nous a demandé une
commission rogatoire internationale pour
aller voir si le rocher monégasque
pouvait avoir une quelconque implication
dans ce dossier
c'est au ministère de la justice de
prendre maintenant une décision on a
appris il ya quelques instants la mise
en examen de cette personne pour
agressions sexuelles non dénonciation et
subordination de témoin parmi elles
trois éducateurs spécialisés d'un
institut pour personnes handicapées de
sissonne dans l'aisne voile avec la
route du rhum laurent bourgnon a repris
la tête sur paul vatine et alain gautier
et ya maintenant la troisième place
voyons maintenant les différentes
options ou stratégiques prises par les
navigateurs loïck peyron a mis le cap au
sud
alors que la plupart des concurrents
choisi la voix du nord
nord au sud la question divise les
routeurs ses équipiers qui à terre avec
les cartes météo dirige les skippers
alexandre kara ne vous fiez pas à ses
images thomas coville surpris au milieu
de l'océan cet après midi n'est pas en
balade et même mieux sur la route des
antilles il est en tête des monocoques
après avoir repris l'aventage sur
catherine chabaud il faut dire que
depuis saint malo ces deux-là nous joue
une échappée dans le plus pur style tour
de france au classement toutes
catégories le numéro un c'est laurent
bourgnon sa bonne fortune le skipper de
primagaz la doit en grande partie aux
routeurs ces terriens qui scrute la
météo
jour et nuit bourgnon qui prend le
meilleur sur paul vatine et alain
gautier
ce n'est pas un hasard mais bien un joli
coup tactique nos deux amis gauthier et
paulo ont décidé de traverser au plus
court pour trouver de l'autre côté en
avant la dépression se ses vents
portants de nord à nord-ouest qui vont
nous permettre de rejoindre le courant
analyser plus au sud
nous on a choisi une politique plus sage
qui le suivent le nord de l'est pression
de façon à voir toujours du vent et si
tous les chemins mènent aux roms il y en
a de plus rapide que d'autres c'est le
nord contre le sud est pour l'instant
pour être honnête l'avantagé aux
nordistes
depuis le départ de la course perron et
joyon les plus sudiste accumule les
retards
c'est pas aveuglément tu descends du
pain sud la france et ce non plus
d'ailleurs
donc on espère un petit retournement de
situation cela dit tu vois le blocage
actuel là ce qui me bloque en ce moment
ses heures perdues j'espère pouvoir les
regagner moment ou un autre mais
j'aurais bien aimé ne pas les perdre en
ce moment c'est à ce moment qu'il
fallait que je recolle puis de possibles
et là on est à la vitesse dramatique on
peut le voir ici vous voyez pas mais de
3 2 6
ce qui n'est pas idéal ça ne fait même
pas la vitesse d'un marchepied pierre
lannier le routeur de peron prévoit un
retournement de situation dans les
prochaines heures
c'est évident beaucoup plus qu'une
bataille navale la route du rhum c'est
aussi le travail des hommes à terre qui
alla sa ble ment décrypte les humeurs de
l'océan
le dernier adieu à jean marais les
habitants de la petite ville de
vallauris ont accompagné jusqu'au vieux
cimetière le comédien à la douleur des
siens et l'émotion des anonymes pour les
obsèques de jean marais yasmina farber
diane richard
à vallauris jean marais était considéré
comme l'enfant du pays
les anonymes avaient donc rendez vous
sur la petite place de l'église
sainte-anne pour un au revoir aux poètes
disparus au premier rang serge marc et
son fils
les potiers jouini pasquali sa deuxième
famille tous ont choisi d'écouter sa
voix son hommage à cocteau je cède la
place abandonne toi la vie est morte
vive la bille le fer marchisio enr a
salué la mémoire d'un homme simple le
ministre de la culture celle d'un héros
capitaine de temps de rêve
il a su rester magie du talent le plus
proche et le plus familier des héros son
image et son nom sont à jamais tissé
dans les toffes de l'une des aventures
créatrice les plus singulières et les
plus attachantes du siècle
la famille du spectacle est venu saluer
l'artiste toutes générations confondues
stanhome dar kifa qui émettent wii fait
quitter doué pour tous et et qu'ils ne
voulaient pas leur valeur reconnaître
qui fait ça par passion et surtout avec
une grande gt c'est surtout sur le plan
humain que vinci prenait le temps de
s'intéresser aux gens le rideau est
tombé sur le vieux cimetière de
vallauris mais les souvenirs ne sont pas
enterrés eastenders ans était depuis
toujours et j'avais régulièrement au
téléphone récemment ils me disaient mes
cascades manque à ces merdes toi je peux
le dire je ne regrette arrière tout
l'après-midi les admirateurs sont venus
fleurir la tombe de jean marais
l'immortel héros de la belle et la bête
est passé de l'autre côté du miroir
cinéma avec la sortie cette semaine de
slam caméra d'or lors du dernier
festival de cannes
une description implacable de l'univers
carcéral américain pour ce film qui
associe acteurs professionnels et
prisonnier slam une sorte de poésie de
la zone incantations des prisonniers un
rap sans musique michel pimont pente et
eric de l'agneau c'est ici que le slam
est né mais pouvait-il naître ailleurs
que derrière ses barreaux
il y a aujourd'hui quatre cent mille
jeunes noirs ont faculté aux états unis
mais ils sont 600 milles en prison
le slam ce sont des improvisations
politique criaient à l'origine de
cellule en cellule pour ne pas crever
tout à fait 10 et les premiers détenus
chaque ce qui m'a le plus choqué ce
n'est pas l'horreur de la prison mais
c'est le talent le sens gens prient
gaspillé derrière les barreaux le slam
est donc issu de ce qu'il faut appeler
le ghetto il s'est nourri imbibé de
violence de crack mais aussi le
désespoir 80% des noirs emprisonné
aujourd'hui le son pour trafic non
violent de drogue douce
c'est la formule administrative employés
je pense que la guerre de la drogue
c'est le grand mensonge
aujourd'hui c'est le vietnam de cette
génération qui pose la question de la
responsabilité individuelle parce qu'on
ne peut pas toujours s'en prendrait aux
blancs gouvernement au système du la
faute aussi se prendre en main tourné
par cet ancien journaliste dans la
prison même de washington avec de vrais
prisonniers jouant leur propre rôle
les moules intérêts sont les plus justes
mais de cette violence semble naître
aujourd'hui un art un art terriblement
vivant et si c'était ça dans la misère
et dans la violence la sortie du tunnel
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres bill
clinton donne une nouvelle chance à la
paix le président américain exhorte
saddam hussein à mettre fin à la crise
vallauris rend un dernier hommage à jean
marais la ville toute entière en deuil
pour les obsèques du comédien l'adieu
des anonymes et des gens du spectacle
dans un instant la bt ou nathalie
rihouet puis le point route valérie
maurice 20h50 un document exceptionnel
réalisé par mireille dumas au coeur des
bleus le portrait du joueur de l'équipe
de france
entourés de leur famille et de leurs
amis 12h45 l'édition de la nuit florence
duprat je vous retrouve demain dès 13
heures je vous remercie de votre
attention
excellente soirée sur france 2
ce soir